for the first time ever tomorrow
Americans nationwide will receive an
alert on their cell phones from
president Trump but it won't be a
personal message it's the first test of
a national presidential alert system
that will let any president issue a
warning about a crisis that could
include a missile launched by another
country at the US or a tsunami first on
CBS this morning Anna Warner got an
inside look at the new system with FEMA
officials ahead of the test and a good
morning good morning you're probably
familiar with the wireless emergency
alert system that generates Amber Alerts
and severe weather warnings to your
phone FEMA says it knows that some
people don't like those alerts but they
say you shouldn't ignore them especially
these new alerts which should signal
very serious situations
it's the alert that if it's real you
won't want to get again when those
messages appear on mobile devices people
should take those extremely seriously it
has some direct impact on either life or
safety
so says FEMA's Antoine Johnson who
directs the agency's public alert
warning system the system that will send
out the nationwide test of the
presidential alert on Wednesday if we
have something that's of national
significance we could rapidly notify the
American public of that event government
agencies nationwide have issued more
than 40,000 emergency alerts to cell
phones since 2012 but those amber and
weather alerts target specific regions
this new presidential alert will be
nationwide and only used for advanced
warning of national crises it should be
reserved for true situations true
emergencies when we need to get the
public's attention former Secretary of
Homeland Security jeh Johnson says it's
designed to be used very specifically
and rarely this is something that should
not be used for a political agenda
he says that's especially important
because no one can opt out of these
alerts you say presidential alert and
some people are thinking oh man I see
president Trump sending out Twitter
messages all day long does this mean I'm
going to get whatever message that
president Trump wants to send out
through this alert system now no not at
all you know one thing that we need to
make very clear is that there are law
policies and procedures that are in
place other protocols to ensure that the
system is used in accordance with its
intended use as defined by the law so if
he wanted to send out an alert that
didn't fit the criteria somebody would
stop him I would say that the protocols
would certainly guide him down a path
that may steer him away from actually
sending that message that does not fit
the criteria but alerts are not
foolproof a missile may enact on land or
sea within minutes in January Hawaii's
Emergency Management Agency mistakenly
sent out an alert warning of a ballistic
missile threat to more than a million
cell phones mistakes like that could
make people nervous about this new
nationwide alert Andy Whitehouse teaches
communications at Columbia University
the fact that you can't turn this alert
off that'll be something that will
arrive on your phone whether you like it
or not I think was perhaps upsetting and
concerning to some people yes it was the
test is scheduled for tomorrow at 2:18
p.m. but three New Yorkers have already
filed a federal lawsuit they filed it
last week attempting to block the test
saying it violates free speech as an N
is an unconstitutional seizure of
electronic devices now the test will set
off the same loud sound used for other
alerts if your cell phone is on and you
have service you will likely receive it
and you cannot stop it Nora
Wow it's really interesting and
everybody's reaction to this I think
it's helpful certainly if there's
something really dangerous there's a
crisis too you have to know if you have
radios you know we don't use radio we
don't use the radios away we used to at
least we all know it's coming tomorrow
at 2:18 that's right and we have to
freak out tomorrow and people in a
situation like that will have been tuned
into CBS this morning so they'll know a
lot before they get their alerts that's
what we do inform people yes yes very
good thanks Anna